so herzlich willkommen zurück in 40 habe
komischerweise wieder level zurück und
simon erzählt euch jetzt warum ich sogar
ich bin ja also ich hätte der letzten
folge sagt ist erzählt wie wir uns
verändert haben es war so wir haben uns
über new york kennengelernt
ohne eine überhaupt nicht doch und lava
student ein rotes stoppschild auf
youtube hater um sich über das ohne not
hätten wir niemals erst mal alles auf
unser allererster oder doch gleich dass
wir uns über youtube kennengelernt haben
weil ohne youtube hätten wir uns oben
nicht kennengelernt
ja ja ich habe nur darüber weil ich
kinder aufhalten
du wolltest vip enchanted werden aber
vorher mussten wir schon mal miteinander
in china und das war nämlich bei dem
neubau mittel bereit sowie games fünf
event und das hat nur noch geleiteten
oder hat mich in die container wo ich
noch relativ neu war in der youtube
szene so war das nämlich überhaupt nicht
doch doch doch also ich hätte aber
meinst du okay also es war so ich war
noch relativ klein ich weiß nicht wie
viele abonnenten da hatte ich glaube
3.000 auf 4.000 weiß nicht ich war grad
also ich habe alles angefangen so zu
sagen ich habe am anfang relativ schnell
die abonnenten bekommen und dann hat
mich eingeladen zu den survival games 5
und bereitet es war dieses match da die
habe ich mit so wenig zusammen mit ihm
gespielt und da war ich auch konkret
drin com kraft hat mit denen zusammen
spielt komplett mit ja doch bloß
gespielt und nur lob hat mit gomez
zusammen gespielt so ballast und in der
konflikte eingeladen und dann war der
concorde seinem alias lukas luca 1
greiff und dann hat hat er habe ich hat
er geschrieben
ich schieß noch umstellen schreib ja
weil meine mutter skype wie sich
unschwer und hat er geschrieben
der ist eigentlich schwer ich hab das
gar nicht wirklich immer so hast du hast
genau ist eigentlich schwer
ja genau und ich habe das so
interpretiert dass es so gestehen was
ist eigentlich und schwer aber ich bin
der geilste erste eindruck kann auch
täuschen ich werde auch gleich sagen ich
jetzt findet und so
dass ich auch gerne mal küsse den spalt
auf jeden fall dann hat der conti gesagt
wer ist eigentlich schwer so richtig ab
werten ist ihr so nach dem motto ich bin
schon der große youtube und der unschwer
ich kenne ich ein deutlicher warum ist
der konfi mit uns nach dem mord das
aufgefallen vielleicht finde ich auch da
vielleicht zu leiden wie gerade in 1 1
vielleicht bin ich da ja auch noch die
sache anders andere araber zur angaben
hat vielleicht gedacht dass er so denkt
vielleicht hat ja auch gar nicht gedacht
sind um meine eigene arbeit eigentlich
meine eigene eindruck so dann hat der
crafter hab ich geschrieben habe ich
geschrien hat irgendwelche leute die er
konnte geschrieben ja ja der ist auch
youtube hat gerade angefangen mit seinem
gelben kanal um gespielt und dann habe
ich geschrieben weil ich natürlich auf
mir sitzen das habe ich geschrieben
wer ist eigentlich luca auch so genau so
ne der ist eigentlich luca und dann hat
da hat ja also wasser genauso arrogant
dauer schwierig war nicht wahr auch
kantig war provokativ
anstatt mir ich lasse mir doch nicht von
hier irgendwelchen leuten an meinem bein
hüpfen und dann doch leute überlegt mal
ich hab gefragt wer ist als würde ich
das bein pissen aufgefasst und dann und
dann hab ich ja warum kannst uns so
aufgefasst habe weil du nicht mitmachst
haye und wer bist du denn eigentlich
sollen dort in der gruppe geschrieben
wer ist eigentlich unschwer du musst
doch er arbeitet die leute gefragt habe
das war eine gruppe mit 30 leuten
ich habe einfach die leute gefragt die
da gerade geschrieben haben wer ist
eigentlich dieser wunsch wäre ja ja weil
ich alle kannte außer dies ja ja auf
jeden fall okay
und dann hab ich geschrieben jetzt
eigentlich luca und dann dann hat
installiert und da hat lukas rupp anlauf
jetzt kommt das arrogante überhaupt
ich bin niemand punkt komplett
kleinkinder eines und punkt ich bin
niemand punkt sollte das war der satz
habe ich nur geschrieben weil du mir
erstmal die frage beantworten sollte ja
ja ich hab das genauso ich gewusst ich
bin ich bin niemand punkt okay er hatte
zu dem zeitpunkt 60 bis 70 tausend
abonnenten schreibt ich bin niemand so
okay was soll ich darauf was solche
unter verstehen ich wusste dass luca com
crafter war ich bin ja nicht doof und
das muss man auch erstmal in frage
stellen und dann hat es karl geschrieben
haha guter witz computer so nach dem
motto das habe ich darauf hinweisen
möchte dass luca kongress ist das muss
ich aber schon
und dann war es gespräch sozusagen schon
beendet zwischen uns und da habe ich
gedacht na klasse fange ich grad mit
youtube an
und machen wir sofort feiern ich hoffe
dass du hast mich dann einfach gespräch
dann kriegt man direkt so irgendwelche
freunde wir führen dass alle darauf
zurück ich habe gefragt wer er ist
genau und dann hast du ich bin niemandem
ja du jetzt mich einfach schreien fragen
können sich in der gruppe so rüber als
nur so nach dem motto ihr könnt ihr euch
ein betreuer angewiesen wäre ob ich da
irgendwie immer reagiert oder ob er
anders reagiert hätte so auf jeden fall
dann war das gespräch beendet zwischen
kommt oft wir haben etwas geschrieben
und alter wassermenge von krassen krater
keine ahnung
und da eine ahnung ach ja der erst
wollte ich bringe jetzt nur ist er als
solist erzähl folge und dann hoffen wir
machen uns auch dann sollen sie sich
verfahren
eine richtig fette fahren
für eine schaufel haben ich mache ganz
wichtig weiter genau damals gespräch
beendet und habe gedacht ja toll fand
ich gerade mit youtube an und machen
direkt zu mit mehr leuten und beliebt
ist schon ziemlich groß sind ja dann und
weil ich denke dann immer so ja komplett
schon ziemlich viel erreicht hat wie
viele bedenken der wahrscheinlich auch
viele leute gehen auf seiner seite steht
und die dann auch jetzt mächtig dahin
können weil kommt oft gesagt boah wie
der party der unsc wertvoll und
geantwortet habe ich das ding gesagt ja
ich denke halt am anfang als ich noch
klein war
da hab ich irgendwie das gefühl gehabt
dass viele von denen minecraft an so ein
bisschen eng geht es zu auf ihre
abonnenten weil ich finde es nämlich
immer ganz furchtbar wenn man plötzlich
mal abonnenten wenn man abonnenten hat
dass man sich für was besseres hätte das
kam mir im moment einfach sofort
ausgeschrieben
ich bin niemand wer ist eigentlich
dieser und es kam einfach so vor als
würde sich für das für den tollsten zu
halten
nur weil du halt mehr abonnenten hat und
dass das ist so weil sache einfach nicht
aber es kam nur sich als fehler passiert
interpretiert und stellte ja gar nicht
und dann war's gespräch wie gesagt
beendet und dann haben wir erst mal ich
hab meine woche oder so nichts
voneinander gehört dann war es eventuell
dann habe ich mental und so weiter und
so fort
in der zeit bin ich halt intrabeam
einmal so richtig abgehen habe so jeden
tag dass wir jetzt durch so eine für
jeden tag tausende kam als gemacht habe
und dadurch halt meine zuschauer so
zusagen bekommen habe weil ich halt sehr
pvp plastik der videos gemacht hat und
dadurch sehr viele zuschauer bekommen
habt die sich für pvp passiert haben und
man sich ungefähr so 10.000 knapp 10.000
abonnenten also 8000 8000 9000 1.000
abonnenten merkt ein alter diese folge
meine tonspur geld einfach so gering
sein
tja und dann und dann dann kam dann kam
kandel und crafter ich hatte zu keinem
kontakt und dann kam ein komplott und da
haben die gesagt welcher in kabul will
allen youtube erklärt wie man die ip
wird
hat kaum kräfte wollten auch vip sein
und dann hat der schwede kann jetzt
erklären und dann kam der computer rein
und dann war da aber ganz korrekt
plötzlich war der ganz anders als ich
dir eigentlich mir gedacht habe ich habe
mit ihm nicht vorher geredet und ich
habe vorhin über ihn geschrieben und da
muss man ganz einfach mit leuten
schreiben leuten redet das sind zwei
verschiedene sachen
und man kann auch zum beispiel ich sage
euch einen tipp noch mal deutlich später
da geht es zum beispiel um mädchen oder
so geht man mit mädchen schreibt und ihr
versteht sich mit ihr super oder so
trifft er sich mit dem mädchen was den
look mit ihnen treibt sondern
telefoniert dass damit der wein mit
leuten nur reel schreibt sind die ganzen
leuten redet kommt auf was genau
umgekehrt ich habe mit ihm geschrieben
dachte er wäre sicher welcher die
welcher junge schreibt er mit ein
bisschen wenig kennt ja klar so ketten
und so ist doch total normal sagt jetzt
wenn man freundin hat aus der schule
dann schreibt man mit der aber dann soll
mit der rede so also über facebook lite
kinder über icq früher war es so ich
weiß nicht ich bin doch schon was älter
darüber hatten wir damals auch egal ob
keller mit super nun mal super den
keller
aber ich sag mal was genau umgekehrt ich
habe ihm geschrieben dass der
feuerlöscher und dafür dem gerät und ab
in einsteins nicht erhöhung von damit
vor mir weil wir auch sympathisch rüber
dann haben wir ein paar mal zusammen
gespielt
direkt und sowas und habe strecke doch
er ist ein echter typ habe ich wohl
falsch eingeschätzt und paar tage später
kam der kontinent angriff gesagt hey
seit ungefähr 10.000 abonnenten hey hast
du lust weil in der ersten folge von
vielleicht auch glaube ich hab jetzt
genau 10.000 abonnenten
das war in den ersten 45 ja das ist
schon so lange her
ja 50 tage fassende ungefähr 50 tage wir
haben 50 tagen habe ich 40.000 jetzt
also haben also madcon crafter bist ein
richtiges team simon 100 kilo hantel
bank gebaut braungebrannte brauchen über
14 und elias ist
auf jeden fall hat es angefangen
ich hatte dann und dann war konnte und
jetzt habe ich mache immer auch viel ist
schon seit 50 tagen gefährt also hatten
und es macht spaß und ich mag kräfte
jetzt und am anfang dachte ich er wäre
als arschloch und jetzt möchte gerne und
die moore aus der geschicht ist der
erste eindruck kann trügen leute vor
allem bedeute nicht redet weil der funke
springt nicht beim schreibt verkehr über
1.11
damit werden die folge wären die folge
ja das war und das war die zweite folge
dann erzählt kommt doch mal was er so
für mich für erste wasser jetzt von mir
hält dann durch sagt bis zu nichts folge
ich habe kein einziges wort gesagt
dieser folge